Stephen Baldwin is not a fan of his  brother Alex Donald Trump impression  tonight I'm going to do three things I'm  going to huff I'm going to puff and I'm  going to blow this whole thing  Alec has been playing the presidential  hopeful all season long for SNL and now  Stephen is speaking out to CBS News  about it we've got the voice down very  well I think it's getting a little too  nasty right now I don't want to be a  party pooper here but I don't think it's  very funny I don't think there's  anything funny about this election I  think it's very serious very important  Stephen is a trump supporter and he  competed on a Celebrity Apprentice twice